[Music]
so Hillary Clinton has a lot of excuses
for why she lost in 2016 and the
presidential election and a brand new
book what happened Clinton details some
of those excuses including the
controversy over her private server
which according to Clinton was just a
dumb scandal driven by partisan politics
like she told that Henry did I clean it
with like a cloth what's this I never
meant to mislead anyone never kept my
email use secret and always took
classified information seriously during
the campaign I tried endlessly to
explain that I'd acted in good faith I
tried to apologize though I knew the
attacks being lobbed at me were untrue
or wildly overstated and motivated by
partisan politics sometimes I dove deep
into the tedious details other times I
tried to rise above it all once I even
told a bad joke no matter what I never
found the right words so let me try
again
it was a dumb mistake but an even dumber
scandal all right
joining us now Fox News contributor
former Arkansas governor Mike Huckabee
you know one of the things we're talking
about tonight governor is equal justice
under the law all right so if you have
equal justice under the law you don't
get to have a private server that was
wrong miss handling is a crime the
leading classified top secret special
access program information that's a
crime
bleach pit acid wash banging out with
hammers phones and blackberries that
would seem like obstruction you know the
Clintons well it doesn't seem like
something to be sorry for and five
foreign intelligence agencies got the
information Shaun forgive me for
laughing during the whole segment but
what I'm sitting here thinking is the
only thing worse than reading the five
hundred and twelve pages would be to
listen to that entire book on audio and
I just cannot imagine that and and part
of it is is that she has this cafeteria
full of excuses as to why she didn't win
but in a serious note one thing I want
people to remember she was in a
pointed federal official at the time
that these things were happening she was
not just a candidate she was the
Secretary of State when she had a
private server she had access to
classified information she was a federal
employee
she was under all of the restrictions
and all of the confines of what that
means and the press has spent so much
time talking about some meeting that one
of Donald Trump's sons had when he was
not a federal employee he was simply the
son of the candidate and it's just
bizarre to me that anybody could with a
straight face think that this was not a
serious issue of what Hillary Clinton
did governor I want to move on to
another issue we've been talking about
this a lot I'm gonna move on to the
agenda of the President and I'm arguing
Republicans don't have an identity
anymore and you know Mitch McConnell
says well there's been excessive
expectations when people thought that if
they got the house and they got the
Senate and they got the White House and
they got a president that wanted to
repeal a replace obamacare that after
eight months they might have the job
done but he says our expectations were
out of whack now he's actually saying
that the tax bill might slip into next
year you know besides raising my blood
pressure and wanting to go apoplectic
over this I'm thinking if you can't get
the job done go get out of the way let's
let somebody who can get the job done is
it do I have excessive expectations no I
think you have the expectations that
were given to you by Senator McConnell
who kept saying give us the Senate we
need the Senate we can't just do it with
the house alone and then we need the
White House well you got all three you
got the house you got the Senate you got
the White House you've had seven and a
half years to prepare and and this is
not about excessive expectations this is
about minimal expectations you were sent
there to cut taxes sent there to repeal
and replace Obamacare defund Planned
Parenthood stop the Iranian deal make
America strong bill the wall for
heaven's sakes these are things you've
got the votes to do so just do it I mean
why don't we kiss and tell them just do
it I agree with you so seven brac
the three middle-class tax cut corporate
tax cut and repatriation and energy
independence I'm not asking for too much
I'm do I'm just asking for what Reagan
did that created 20 million new jobs I
don't think that's that hard it's not
that hard and the thing is it would have
an incredible impact upon exploding the
economy with extraordinary growth the
growth is is far more important than
anything else we do because that's how
we pay for the entitlements that's also
how we bring down the debt we'll never
be able to tax people enough the only
way to get our economy under control our
debt under control have the defense
budget we need get people back to work
and getting paychecks instead of welfare
checks it's real simple grow the economy
and a tax plan what Donald Trump has
suggested will do that and when Mitch
McConnell interjects himself in a
primary in Alabama and the people of
Alabama latest polls show 52% Roy Moore
and and Luther strange is at thirty five
or six percent that says a lot doesn't
it and he's at 18 percent approval
rating in the state of Kentucky well I
think it does and one of the reasons I
supported Roy Moore in this Senate race
I don't have anything against Luther
strange he may be a great guy but Shawn
it's real simple I want someone who will
go and challenge the establishment not
be a part of it and I'm convinced Roy
Moore will at least challenge it and he
won't join the club I don't want any
more members of their club I don't want
any more members of the club to set a
dining room the Senate barber shop the
Senate workout room how about the Senate
work for the people rule let's have one
of those rooms all right good to see you
governor thank you